well I think like um a couple of things
to clear up because I do think that now
that obviously
the trial and you know everything is
passed you could you could speak for the
most part for the most part I gotta go
to jail for no [__] I ain't gonna say
for no [__] reason but how long are
you guys we'll see It'll be up to the
judge
maybe a year maybe longer maybe maybe
less maybe the judge would be like you
know you ain't been in no trouble before
this or after this so you know you it
was an isolated incident a jealous
bottom feeder predicate felon bum ass
[__] hater that you know [__]
gasoline on the fire so well I think um
because kind of helped me walk me
through this because
taxton's lawyer his name is redstone we
address people probably
listen the guy's in jail you won he's in
jail it doesn't matter Bing is dead uh
it ain't no you know what I'm saying
like so this is levels his levels to
winning and [__] you feel for sure I had
lost custody in my kids I had to fight
for that I had to pay over 200 000 loyal
fees
yes oh all of these type of [__] that I
had to go through my career was crippled
right like it ain't you can't you can't
I'm I'm kicking a [__] scumbag
cockroaches when they down you feel me
I'm a step with them it's gonna be guts
from the bottom of my shoe his name is
redstone he wrote a letter to the judge
and his whole defense was that he didn't
kill Banger Troy Ave did it wrestle for
the gun and Troy have shot his friend so
he's a [__] rat and he's a [__]
cockroach and he's a bottom feeder and
we need to remove haters from the
[__] Community we need remove them
they need to be treated with the same
disdain as we do [__] snitches that
do crowns with their homies and turn
around and flip on them as we do it
child molesters as we do with rapists
all these type of people because haters
are cancer and that [__] spews over to
other people well that's what I was
gonna say so I've this you know I think
that the one thing about this gentleman
is he does have a lot of Industry
friends right and so me being somebody
who was actually friends with Banga
right I think I had a lot of love for
you
I never was like
free dude [__] that like dude killed my
boy you know what I'm saying like I
personally like it is what it is I'm not
in the situation I wasn't there but like
um I think that the the I do think that
the reason why you're not necessarily
going
through a lot of the backlash that like
um maybe a guy like six nine went
through is because the situation
at least how it's been explained is
you just cleared your name up after a
lawyer essentially wrote a letter
pinning everything on you well it wasn't
so much a lawyer it was so much him you
can't do anything without your lawyer's
approval you have to give your lawyers
information his lawyers is not coming up
with alleged crimes that we was involved
in that's him being a goddess in the
know of Street things you know what I'm
saying it's not his lawyer is not coming
up with this info so they wrote a letter
to the judge but even before that the
whole defense was that you know I
you know what I'm saying like just just
Coney [__] that we're not going for and
as far as like me and six nine is
totally different because
six nine is it or was an active gang
member when you win gang [__] that [__]
is in the streets you keep that [__] in
the streets I don't care if somebody
rapes your mother you go kill them oh
you have whatever happens to them right
you it don't be no police [__] involved
oh my street business I kept in the
streets I got shot when I was 15. you
never heard about it it's in the streets
I barely don't even rap about it right I
got shot in my head on Christmas Day
yeah I was there the Polk detectives was
at my best side I ain't have nothing to
say because we kept that in the streets
this [__] is the internet this [__] is
the same thing that would this is like a
stalker somebody who would tweet
somebody 780 times over a five-year
period this is craziness it's like the
person who killed John Lennon the the
[__] who killed Selena even though she
wasn't a stalker she was an assistant
right like this is a totally different
situation you feel me this started in
the public and you don't never allow
nobody to just say I'ma crash out throw
my life away and I'm taking you down
down with me now get the [__] over me
you go up that bridge yourself don't
yeah get off my body right right right
right right and I do think too like you
know you said let her aside that it was
a situation that was but I do think the
letter kind of like at least optically
kind of like is like hey
definitely you know what I mean like you
want me to just like go with what this
letter says you want me to hold myself
down you feel me yeah you wanna you
wanna play it fair you wanna you wanna
play fit and inside that you know I
would even let somebody determine the
Rules of Engagement rules of the game
you know what I'm saying which it
happened but then it's like wait hold on
this we both in the ring box and this
person took the gloves off and you know
I mean they they spray some [__] in my
eyes what the [__] I'm supposed to do I
wanted to talk to you because
um and the real ones are seeing that if
you look at the public opinion even with
people like my son is generally these
nuts attacks you rob he'll put up a post
and people will be under his comments
like [__] you talking about each other I
have a real [__] you bugging he did
what most rappers talk about doing you
want him to take the murder of his
friend you want to take attempted murder
on somebody that shot him and he took
the gun from like people in the comments
right even when chano put up a post like
these guys got to make their comments
limited when you say Channel yeah man
you know exactly who he is I love Mano
man I was just in uh Emmanuel doesn't
love you you love him he doesn't love
you it may not solid he's a good guy
what is he done good I mean
well that's how you judge a man you're
judging me his character by their
actions but you and may not have great
records together you guys you've done
favors for him and I've and I've done
records and I've carried I mean it was
on your album too no he's only he wasn't
in New York City [__] no no what was the
record oh no I'm thinking of Prodigy I'm
thinking of The Prodigy when I do albums
I'm meticulous with them [__] no no no
I'm thinking about that yeah
people who I admire on New York City the
album not just whoever is you never
admired Mano ever
I supported because he was from from
Brooklyn right and he was coming up I'm
always support I'm I show love right you
know what I'm saying always I show love
that's how I'm always show up so I
bought this album when it came out it
was trash you know what I'm saying
whatever that was trash though
well there's only one that I was the
first album was great his first time
come on no no that I'm on it here we go
here we go with the cats
the first album was great right his
debut album on Atlantic was crazy the
first album was great it was great is it
better than he had a record on their car
Soldier I bet she was it it's not better
than him and I'm not even gonna say
classic like outcasts and [__] like that
since you seen hours
no I think this is one of the greatest
albums ever okay see you don't got a
bunch of albums over here
um now I got some here
it's better than this but I'm not going
I'm not I think it's better by end he
can never do nothing better than I think
maino's first he got him is better than
that album from nas his first album
because he's put out other albums
through Empire and [__] oh what bro his
first album was hard oh we got seriously
looking to you we gotta look down bro
you don't even saying that that's not
true you I'm telling you who you and him
his kid now mano's album is hard bro his
first album what it's good take it so
people get in the comments yeah tell me
your comments and especially from New
York my bandana Soldier he has some [__]
on that first time all right so if you
call his album great what would you call
New York City album if you had to rate
them from one attack I think it's a
better album like if you have I want to
see how you know I'm a huge fan of of
New York City I think that's your best
album I want to see
it you think major you haven't really
hate I win yet then um that's more of
everything but what
when you say great album if on a scale
of one to ten if New York City the album
was a 10 or whatever you want to call it
what would that album be because we got
a deal in facts here we're gonna bring
the facto show to my God [__] and we
only our opinion is always based on
facts okay so what would be would get
rich or die trying to be a 10 yeah
absolute a lot of things I won't
I'm gonna say like a 9.8 I'm I'm okay
get rich or die trying to get rich I got
a personal thing with like 50 Cent my
favorite get rich or die trying is a 10.
New York City the album for me is like a
like a Hard Eight okay and I think
maino's album's like a seven and a half
seven are you sitting me his first album
is fire bro let's go to Pitchfork
because Pitchfork actually just worked
they give people zeros that's a bunch of
[__] Williamsburg [__] weenies in
tight pants [__] rating albums
[__] pictures oh you say it's a great
album because they had it right now
is it lyricism
it was a concept album
voice records
it was a good concept it started off
with him getting freed from jail I like
the album oh you want me to that's it no
no it's objective no I just want to know
why your opinion is like that because I
want it because people have opinions why
am I why are like mano's first album
yeah like I went like I know I mean I
don't want to know anymore but I just I
was saying like your opinion like I
think it was I'll tell you why I Love YG
album his first album oh my crazy Life's
a classic for sure it's what I'm trying
to say it's about an it's like a 9.2
when we say greats and Classics now most
people would tell you New York City
album is a classical amazing what I'll
do is classical new pop that's what most
people will tell you it was the classics
now
I'm not gonna toot my own on my new [__]
but I've never heard nobody say his [__]
was a classic and we got to be careful
with the titles that we give today well
I didn't say I didn't say classic I said
it was a great album though
what I mean great album so we have bad
albums good albums great albums
something else and then Classics or yeah
all right so it's made
it's a great album yeah if we got two
levels above it it's made two levels
above it two levels below I just want
with hip-hop is too much gray areas like
when you see I mean it's all objective
it's all winning hip-hop award this is
also objective to like what I serious
people there's people who lit who love
Playboy cardi I don't agree with them
well but but that's the thing it's
subjective we have if we have a uh if we
have a grading system and a formula
there's no formula because everyone's
grading system and formula is different
that's what I'm trying to say that's
what we need if we have a great somebody
some people might say like I might be
like yo
Augustine is my favorite player I know
Jordan is better but Iverson is my goat
you know what I'm saying exactly but I
can say why okay Jordan is better for
these reasons you know what I'm saying
no I'm not the same way I feel about
like a lot of rap [__] I could be like
Pusha T is in my top five or maybe my
top like eight push it t you'd probably
top
see now you saying overall if I'm
talking about drugs
my personal favorites Pusha T's in my
top ten yeah hands down
if you were to have me put together like
the not bootleg cab10 push is not in the
top ten okay so you mean but I'm putting
him high as [__] on my [__] right
that's right he's right there you know
what I'm saying I got Tupac up there I
just got into a [__] argument with
Jim Jones that went viral over him
saying Pusha T was in top 50. I was like
you're [__] crazy yeah I heard it but
I heard about him saying it on like top
50. that's crazy it's a wild wild
statement